[Music]
Hercules the strongest man alive with a
mighty heart to match Orpheus charmer of
nature and master of music castor and
pollux the twin tricksters hatched from
an egg
the bori adds sons of the north wind who
could hurdle through the air for untold
times these heroes had roamed ancient
Greece creating new legends wherever
they went but none of their adventures
was so great as when they joined forces
for the sake of a young man named Jason
years before Jason's uncle Elias had
ruthlessly usurped the throne of
Thessaly from Jason's grandfather when
Jason returned to his father's stolen
court the cowardly King set him a
seemingly impossible task crossed the
teeming seas to Colchis and steal the
Golden Fleece of a flying ram under King
ie T's nose if Jason retrieved the
fleece pelléas promised to relinquish
the throne touched by his heroic mission
the gods spread Jason's call for help
and soon he had assembled a not so
motley crew
these heroes alongside countless sailors
of soothsayers and rebel demigods named
themselves the Argonauts
after their sturdy ship but the path
ahead was marked with untold terrors
enough to test even the fiercest heroes
their first stop was Lemnos an isle of
women who had killed all the island's
men as punishment
Aphrodite had cursed them with a
sickening stench but that didn't stop
Jason fathering twins with the Queen
the rest of the crew also found
themselves embroiled in new romances
until Hercules chastised them for not
behaving like heroes eventually they
sailed on to the mount of bears an
island where a group of ancient six
armed monsters lived alongside the
peaceful de Leone's while the clan
welcomed the Argonauts with open arms
the monsters surged down from the
mountains and hurled rocks at the dock
ship Hercules held them off
single-handedly before his comrades
joined the fray bolstered by their
victory the triumphant heroes sailed
onward only to be blown back to the
island several stormy nights later in
the tempest the DA Lyonnaise thought
these new arrivals invaders the
Argonauts were similarly unaware of
their surroundings and fought blundering
Lea in the dark
slaying wave after wave of foe but the
morning light revealed a horrible truth
their victims were none other than their
previous hosts yet again
Jason had allowed the crew to be
distracted this time at a terrible cost
ashamed had his conduct he resolved to
focus only on the fleece but even this
hast proved ruinous when Hercules Squire
was abducted by a water nymph Jason
sailed on oblivious to the absence of
his most powerful crew mate
the remaining Argonauts continued their
quest until stopping at the sight of an
old man surrounded by a swirl of harpies
this was Phineas a seer cursed by Zeus
to endure old-age blindness and endless
torture for giving away his prophesies
moved by his plight the wind brothers
set upon the flock providing phineas
with a brief respite from his punishment
in return the seer told them how to
overcome the terrifying trial that lay
ahead the simply Gattis a pair of
clashing rocks that reduced ships to
splinters but first the Argonauts would
have to maneuver past the mouth of hell
around the island of the bloodthirsty
Amazons and under psychedelic skies
these adventures cost the crew both in
men and morale and some feared they
might be losing their minds upon
reaching the clashing rocks the
exhausted crew quaked with fear but
Phineas's advice rang in their heads the
Argonauts released a single dove and
sped through in its wake to emerge
unscathed with this narrow escape the
Argonauts finally had Colchis in their
sights yet while Jason rested and
celebrated with his crew he could feel
his time among them was drawing to a
close as the fleece gleamed in his mind
he knew he would have to retrieve it
alone but he could not guess that this
final task would have the most horrible
price of all if you enjoy playing
witness to the clashes between gods and
mortals
we highly recommend Madeline Miller's
Cersei this epic saga of love loss magic
and immortality weaves together some of
our favorite myths download an audio
version for free at audible.com slash
Ted - Edie